- [Conan] Believe it or not
Comic-Con isn't the only thing
going on this week, the
Republican National Convention
is also happening in Cleveland, yup.
(audience booing)
So there are a lot of fans here.
In honor of both conventions happening
at the same time, we thought
it'd be fun to bring out
someone who represents both Comic-Con
and the Republican party.
He's here tonight.
Please welcome Captain
Make America Great Again!
(cheering, clapping)
(grandiose music)
- [Captain] Thanks, Conan.
I've waited a very long time to be here.
I have to tell you.
- [Conan] We're all thrilled to have you,
Captain Make America Great Again.
- [Captain] Agreed, Conan.
Now listen.
Booking me is going to
be huge for America.
Which needs my super
powers now more than ever.
- [Conan] Okay, I'm sorry, what exactly
are your super powers?
- [Captain] Well, I have all
the best super powers, Conan.
(audience laughing)
Believe me, I know super powers.
- [Conan] Okay, I just didn't
know you had any super powers.
I'm not sure about that.
- [Captain] Look, look, look, look.
This city needs me, all right.
I was walking around San
Diego today and frankly,
this place is a dump.
I have to tell you.
(audience booing)
A dump.
- [Conan] Wow, wow.
- [Captain] Thank you, thank you.
It's overrun, it's overrun with Wookies,
zombies, and Klingons.
(audience cheering)
- [Conan] That's what it's supposed to be.
It's Comic-Con.
- [Captain] Well, let
me say this, all right.
That Klingon planet, they're
not sending us their best.
All right?
(audience laughing)
It's true.
We're getting rapist Klingons.
- [Conan] No, no we're not, no.
- [Captain] Drug dealing Klingons.
- [Conan] That's not true, no.
- [Captain] And they all
seem very, very angry
and none of them speak English.
- [Conan] Okay, that's offensive.
Everything you just
said is very offensive.
- [Captain] Conan, Conan,
I am going to build a wall.
- [Conan] No, no.
- [Captain] Between all
the planets and I will make
the aliens pay for it.
- [Conan] That's not, no.
You should go.
I think you should go.
Your views are not welcome here.
- [Captain] I will make San
Diego and America great again!
(audience booing)
Thank you, thank you.
Because I am the hero Comic-Con needs
and the one it deserves.
- [Conan] Yeah.
(audience booing)
That's great, that's great.
- [Captain] Hail Hydra!
(cheering, clapping)
- [Conan] Captain Make
America Great Again.
You should go.
We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)
Nick Kroll is here, stick around.